Napoléon Gengis Khan Alexandre le Grand
Jules César ces grandes figures
historiques sont réputées pour être des
conquérants mais parmi eux lequel peut
être considéré comme le plus grand
conquérant Thibault de la chaîne
Histoire appliquée est ici dans
l'atelier pour nous répondre allez chers
on vous embarque pour un bon dans le
temps et dans l'histoire
et oui j'ai mis c'est une très bonne
question qui est le plus grand
conquérant de l'histoire pour y répondre
il faut commencer par se poser une autre
question sur quels critères doit-on se
baser alors si la grandeur était
proportionnelle à la taille pas sûr que
Napoléon l'emporterait il ne mesurait
qu'un mètre 68 cela dit il y a fort à
parier que Jules César et Gengis Khan
n'était pas beaucoup plus grand plus
sérieusement la réponse à cette question
dépend principalement du référentiel tu
raisonnes en termes de territoires
conquis le grand gagnant et Gengis Khan
le mongole avec l'aide de ses
redoutables cavaliers il a réussi à
constituer un empire qui va de la
Méditerranée à la mer du Japon soit plus
de 30 millions de kilomètres carrés si
l'on se réfère à l'impact sur nos
institutions contemporaines Napoléon
remporte la partie haut la main la
France a conservé certaines institutions
mises en place par l'empereur c'est le
cas d'une bonne partie du code civil
l'organisation en département la Banque
de France et sans parler du paysage
l'Arc de Triomphe les platanes sur les
bords des routes et plusieurs dizaines
de monuments dans tout le pays sinon sur
l'héritage culturel européen Jules César
et les romain en général pour y réclamer
la première marche du podium plusieurs
langues européennes sont issues du latin
comme le français l'italien ou
l'espagnol de même la culture des
Romains a considérablement influencé les
arts à la Renaissance mais aussi
l'architecture et la politique les rois
et empereur s'en sont souvent inspirés
pour eux-mêmes avoir l'air de héros
antique et marquer l'histoire tu vois
Jamie c'est une question de point de vue
et je n'oublie pas que dans ta liste il
y en a un dont on n'a pas parlé c'est
Alexandre le Grand
et c'est justement lui qui selon moi
mérite le titre de plus grand conquérant
on impacte politique et culturel a été
si fort en son temps qu'il a laissé des
traces plus de 2300 ans après et pour
comprendre mon choix il faut se pencher
sur son incroyable épopée Alexandre le
Grand est né en 356 avant l’air
chrétienne en Macédoine alors la
Macédoine à l'époque ça n'est pas une
salade de légumes mais un petit pays
situé entre la Grèce actuelle et un état
plus récent que l'on nomme la Macédoine
du Nord il y a 2400 ans les Macédoniens
sont considérés comme des demi grecques
ou des demi barbares pas vraiment des
Grecs donc mes proches de tout de même
le pays est d'ailleurs fortement
influencé par la culture grecque à cette
époque la Grèce n'est pas un pays un
territoire composé de plusieurs grandes
cités puissantes et indépendantes la
Macédoine elle est bien un pays c'est
une monarchie élective où le roi est
donc élu enfin ça c'est la théorie dans
les faits les fils succès d'opères qui
eux-mêmes succède à leur père qui
eux-mêmes succède à leur père etc ce non
respect de la règle élective entraîne de
nombreuses querelles concerne parfois
très violente qui font de la Macédoine
un pays profondément instable toutefois
ce désordre fait des heureux la cité
d'Athènes et l'approche région grecque
de Thessaly profite de ceux des ordres
pour tirer parti des richesses et des
pores accédoniens l'avenir du pays et
donc plutôt un certain c'est dans ce
contexte troublé que Philippe le père
d'Alexandre le Grand arrive au pouvoir
et il ne tarde pas à rétablir l'ordre en
quelques années il parvient à imposer de
grandes réformes qui assurent la paix
avec les voisins belliqueux il en
profite aussi pour solidifier et
stabiliser le système politique
macédonien il crée par exemple une armée
de métiers articulée autour d'une
infanterie lourde équipée de grandes
piques qu'on appelle des cerises on y
trouve également une cavalerie puissante
et des trous plus légères pour appuyer
cet enfant très lourde Philippe est
aussi un habile politicien ce grand roi
va de succès en succès tant militaire
qu’économique sous son règne la
Macédoine devient l’une des premières
puissances financières du monde c'est
désormais un pays avec lequel les cités
grecques mais également la grande Perse
de voir composer mais elle était 336
avant l’air chrétienne coup de théâtre
Philippe est assassiné le meurtrier
n'est autre qu'un de ses gardes du corps
il se murmure que le commanditaire
serait en réalité Olympias son épouse la
mère d'Alexandre en histoire de jalousie
peut-être la question reste sans réponse
ce qui est sûr en revanche c'est que ce
meurtre propulse soudainement le jeune
Alexandre sur le trône n'a pas encore 20
ans et possède déjà une solide
expérience de la guerre et à participer
à certains des exploits militaires de
son père et s'est révélé un excellent
meneur d'homme Alexandre veut à présent
poursuivre seul l’œuvre de Philippe et
aller chercher sa propre gloire ce ne
sera pas dans un énième conflit avec les
Grecs les relations de la Macédoine avec
ses voisins semble enfin apaiser pour
Alexandre Leny à abattre c'est la Perse
il rêve d'unir Lorient et l'Occident et
répandre la culture hellénistique
partout dans le monde la Perse immense
empire oriental qui s'étend de la Libye
à l'Inde actuelle est sur le chemin de
ses rêves en plus d'être un réservoir
inépuisable d'hommes et de richesse
c'est aussi une puissance belliqueuse
qui a de nombreuses fois tenter de
conquérir les cités grecques envahir
cette superpuissance de l'époque c'est
donc le premier objectif d'Alexandre il
lance une première offensive en 334
avant l'air chrétienne c'est la bataille
de granit dans les Dardanelles qui se
solde par un succès éclatant Alexandre
n'aurait perdu que 110 hommes sur une
armée qui en comptait 35000 c'est
probablement un peu exagéré
sur sa lancée le jeune conquérant décide
de poursuivre sa route sans trop
s'éloigner des côtes et il remporte une
nouvelle bataille à isos en Syrie cette
fois l'armée Perse est écrasée elle ne
parvient plus à offrir de résistance à
Alexandre qui poursuit son périple sur
d'autres territoires bordant la
Méditerranée il arrive ainsi à tire un
immense porthénicien mais ici les choses
s'avèrent beaucoup plus compliqué en
effet tir est une ville fortifiée située
sur une île la configuration difficile
des lieux empêche les armées d'Alexandre
d'être pleinement efficace quant aux
phénicien il se battent comme des lions
et refuse de se rendre c'est le point de
départ d'un siège qui sera long et
difficile pour les Macédoniens il faut
huit mois à Alexandre pour arriver à ses
fins mais une fois d'en tir il ne se
contente pas de prendre le contrôle de
la ville il en profite pour réduire sa
population à l'esclavage pour l'exemple
fort de son succès il libère l’égypte de
la domination perse et se fait proclamer
pharaon dans la foulée au même moment un
autre événement fini de lui donner une
aura exceptionnelle un miracle lui
annonce qu'il n'est pas le fils de
Philippe mais bien le fils de 200
personnes le dieu des dieux et ça change
tout aux yeux de tous Alexandre est
désormais perçue comme un demi dieu il
est acclamé comme un libérateur adulé
par ses hommes et admiré par la plupart
de ses contemporains pourtant le jeune
chef n'en est encore au début de ses
conquêtes il faut attendre 331 avant
l'ère chrétienne et la bataille de
gogame pour avoir une nouvelle
démonstration de son génie militaire
Alexandre fait alors subir une terrible
humiliation à Darius III roi des rois
Perse pourtant à la tête d'une armée 6
fois supérieure en ombre à la sienne
Babylone suce Persepolis toutes les
grandes villes Perses tombent les unes
après les autres Darius et misérablement
assassinés lors de sa fuite face à
l'avancée d'Alexandre ce dernier est
désormais maître de l'Empire qu'il
convoitait il n'a pas l'intention de
s'arrêter en si bon chemin il poursuit
son aventure toujours plus à l'est
jusqu'à l'actuel Pakistan au pied de
l'Himalaya il fait la connaissance de
peuple dont personne n'en Macédoine née
en Grèce ne soupçonnait l'existence
toutefois après près de dix de bataille
de voyage et de conquêtes le Conquérant
se voit contraint de faire demi-tour son
armée est à bout de souffle il
s'installe définitivement à Babylone la
nouvelle capitale de son gigantesque
empire qui s'étend du Pakistan à la
Grèce en 323 avant l'ère chrétienne à
Babylone Alexandre tir sa révérence cet
homme que rien ne semblait pouvoir
arrêter terrassé par la maladie il n'a
que 32 ans après sa mort son empire sera
partagé entre ses plus fidèles généraux
mais ces royaumes de culture grecque
souvent instables et éphémères cette peu
à peu la place à la nouvelle puissance
montante de l'antiquité Rome on a
souvent tendance à définir Alexandre
comme un génie militaire et un homme
cruel ces grandes batailles les
habitants de tir réduit en esclavage et
la ville de Persépolis entièrement
brûlée en sont de bons exemples on ne
peut donc pas nier que la violence soit
indissociable de son règne mais ce
serait une erreur que de le réduire à
cela dans les territoires conquis il n'a
pas toujours été considéré comme un
tyran sanguinaire bien au contraire
Alexandre s'est attaché à pacifié les
zones qu'il occupaient son objectif
était de créer un immense territoire de
culture grecque dans le respect des
usages locaux il a ainsi favorisé la
création de cités et de colonies mixtes
entre Grecs et natifs une grande idée
même s'il n'est pas exclu qu'il soit
parvenu par la force il n'a pas cherché
non plus à gommer les langues
autochtones et à veiller au respect des
traditions dans chaque pays il semble
également avoir pris le parti de
conserver les administrations en place
en se contentant de les améliorer la
présence d'Alexandre le Grand aurait
donc aussi été bénéfique au peuple
conquis il a renforcé le système
monétaire construit de nouveaux réseaux
routiers et fonder un certain nombre de
villes plus célèbre étant bien sûr
Alexandrie Alexandrie mais je parle de
celle d'Egypte parce qu'Alexandre avait
tendance à appeler toutes les villes
qu'ils fondaient Alexandrie et il en
aurait fondé entre 20 et 70
il fut donc un conquérant mais aussi un
homme à l'ambition civilisatrice qui
restera un modèle pour beaucoup dans
l'Antiquité son oeuvre militaire fascine
les plus grands hommes Jules César se
réclame de l'héritage d'Alexandre comme
nombre d'empereurs romains par la suite
plus tard au Moyen-Âge le Macédonien est
l'un des héros les plus connus de la
littérature médiévale grâce au roman
d'Alexandre il s'agit d'un recueil de
légendes et de poèmes autour de sa vie
qui sera traduit dans des dizaines de
langues partout dans le monde en Europe
tous les grands monarques chercheront à
s'inspirer d'Alexandre le Grand le plus
célèbre d'entre eux c'est Napoléon
l'empereur les riches en modèle c'est
une inspiration pour sa capacité à
organiser son armée et les territoires
conquis aujourd'hui encore les Batailles
d'Alexandre sont analysées dans les
écoles d'officiers pour les historiens
contemporains le personnage conserve
malgré tout une grande part d'ombre a
commencé par les circonstances de sa
mort a-t-il succombé à une maladie à un
empoisonnement le débat n'est pas tout à
fait tranché même si l'hypothèse de la
maladie reste tout de même la plus
probable mais la plus grande question
non résolue concerne le lieu de sa
sépulture personne n'en connaît
l'emplacement il fut pourtant bien connu
jusqu'à la fin de l'Empire romain les
empereur allait régulièrement si
recueillir certains pour lui rendre
hommage comme Auguste d'autres pour
chiper des morceaux de sa tenue
funéraire en guise de relique et puis un
beau jour mon père sa trace son tombeau
a-t-il été déplacé a-t-il été détruit
nous n'avons absolument pas la réponse
chaque année ou presque il y en a
toujours un pour affirmer qu'il a mis la
main sur le tombeau d'Alexandre mais
bien sûr et bien c'est du vent la
question continue d'alimenter tous les
fantasmes pour finir je ne résiste pas
au plaisir de vous raconter une petite
anecdote concernant l'héritage
d'Alexandre c'est l'histoire de la Cozia
il s'agissait d'une sorte de béret plat
plus ou moins grand que portaient les
combattants de Macédoniens et les
monarques ce couvre-chef placé sous le
casque en temps de guerre devait être
très utile il permettait de créer un
rembourrage qui absorbait les chocs et
améliorer le confort des guerriers et ce
béret ne vous dit rien il ressemble
comme deux gouttes d'eau au pacole le
fameux chapeau afghan porté aujourd'hui
par les combattants dans cette région du
monde selon la légende les Afghans et
les Pakistanais auraient adopté la kosia
après le passage des armées d'Alexandre
puis il aurait traversé les âges jusqu'à
nous alors pourquoi Alexandre est selon
moi le plus grand des conquérants parce
qu'elle cumulent tous les critères des
autres conquérants vaste territoire
conquis comme Gengis Khan réorganisation
administrative et trace durable dans
notre quotidien comme Napoléon et impact
culturel et politique comme les Romains
après Alexandre toute personne
ambitieuse s'inspirera de lui et c'est
bien pour ça qu'il a acquis ce surnom
d'Alexandre le Grand voilà j'ai mis
j'espère que ta voix convaincu
qu'Alexandre le Grand est bien le plus
grand des grands conquérants merci
Thibault si comme moi cette vidéo vous a
passionné n'hésitez pas à liker et à
vous abonner si toutefois vous aviez des
suggestions de sujets liés à l'histoire
n'hésitez pas à proposer les en
commentaire à très bientôt chers
épicurieuses et épicurieux
[Musique]